if you were trapped in a psychedelic
Journey for the ages what would you do a
magical trinket called the bloom is
causing destruction to the entire world
and only a naked swamp which can stop it
I'm here to break down the mistakes made
what you should do and how to beat the
bloom in spine of the night this naked
Witch is going to find herself in a
world of trouble traversing through a
frozen tundra the Fallen witch Queen's
odd here makes her way up a snowy
mountain with only one goal in her mind
reclaim what was stolen from her she
makes it up the Steep a Mountainside
finding a large skull formation buried
into the ground Zod walks closer and
stumbles Upon A mysterious looking shrub
that's when the sword wielding Guardian
stands up from his Slumber to confront
her informing the witch that what she's
staring at is the bloom the last Light
of the Gods and threatens to kill her if
she tries to take it Zod insists that
she comes in peace and the man orders
her to turn back the witch Queen informs
him that the bloom is weakening which
pisses him off even further she brings
out another flower from her chest and
explains that the bloom has spread
throughout the lands coming from one
spot of Bloom and she's here to relieve
him of his Guardian Services mentioning
that she only regrets that it took so
long to find him the man questions how
she arrived at the same time that the
bloom began to wither growing suspicious
of what changed in the world below them
Zod reveals that her home the Great
Swamp of bastai was destroyed and she
used to serve as a leader to her land's
worshipers this is all extremely
confusing and is about to get a whole
lot more weird but follow along she
decides to explain the entire story of
how she arrived here from the top to
bottom back to the swamp while chanting
to a bunch of other scantily clad
hippies Zod orders her followers to
stare into the fire and she throws a
number of flowers from her trinket
causing a blue flame to emerge from
their big bonfire suddenly Invaders
attack and brutally take out members of
her tribe and she orders them to fight
back they do try their best to fight off
the armed attackers managing to kill
some of the armored men but it's not
enough Zod here watches as the
worshipers around her are brutally torn
apart at every single way that you can
think of in a dark fantasy anime she
then gets restrained by the mongrel
leader who pulls her towards him
ordering his men to chain her up and
take this witch Queen along with them
leaving the swamp the mongrel welcomes
her to civilization informing the girl
that she's been taken hostage at the
request of his master they enter the
village as this horse riding man Gaul
sewer Falls from behind and is stopped
by these guards who ask him what is an
outsider doing here he reveals that Lord
pyranton has requested a scholar to
record the growth of their City they
reluctantly led him through as the
scholar rides through the creepy looking
town he walks inside this darkened
castle and sees a certain somebody to do
something really nasty unfortunately are
very not suitable for YouTube and then
sees this dude wearing a goat head peek
around from behind the door once again
this world is seriously messed up and
full of a lot of nasty things I don't
want to even know what's going on behind
that tour and thankfully neither does
golf soar ignoring the uh definite red
flags he just witnessed golf sewer makes
his way into the main chamber and
introduces himself to Lord pyranton
who's absolutely tested the Lord says
hello and oh by the way how long does it
take for him to arrive from his City to
this castle and he is told that it only
takes a day's ride Lord piranted freaks
out and demands to know why it took
months for a scholar to come here and
Mark his achievements regarding their
City's exponential growth golfer
apologizes and comments on his father's
quickly expanding Empire but the Lord
interrupts insisting that he forget
about his father's achievements and
focus on the city that they're standing
in he assures The Scholar that this city
will be the spirit tip of the Empire
very soon that's when he mentions to
Gaul sewer of a very important day they
finally removed the roadblock the swamp
people who have been halting their
progress he orders the scholar to sit
down and tells him to pay attention
demanding they bring in the witch Zod
walks inside and the woman is brought to
Lord piranton she tries to attack the
Lord but is pushed over being informed
that struggling will only make it worse
Lord pyranton asks her why she leads the
swamp tribe all sorrow angered Zod tells
him that the Great Swamp is is called
bastai giving whoever loves her peace
and Harmony very nice the Lord insists
that he'll take whatever he wants from
the swamp and orders his lackeys to keep
her still and he's given a whip which he
tells galsua to record each and every
time he hits her marks down this
momentous moment in history this man is
sick of the head and he has access to
way too much power for his own good okay
this is some highly sickening stuff that
we're dealing with right now I've seen a
lot of anime but I've never seen a
foreign fantasy anime world go from 0 to
100 so quickly it's not looking like
this is your usual kind of unicorn and
fairies anime Universe everyone around
is hot here is an outright killer and we
need to take this situation with extreme
care if we want to survive let's just
assume that we can't use any kind of
extreme magic to help us out of our
chains though that would be very
convenient so that means we're trapped
with heavy metal weighing us down
looking around the room we need to
assess what's around us and who's around
us and what we can use to get the hell
out of here this may look like an
unbeatable situation but zot is lucky
enough to have a few key things in her
favor always remember in life it's good
to stay very calm in life or death
incidents because even one wrong move or
misstep could mean an ax to our neck
okay first off one she isn't actually
chained to anything that's keeping her
in place that's good which means that
running away is a possibility we need to
be super calm and relaxed and look
around very casually and see where the
front door is and remember Zod was only
dragged here recently which is a
positive thing that we can lean on in
fact while These Chains might seem like
a horrible inconvenience to deal with
the way that it's made and shaped can
actually be used in our favor assuming
that the wrist locks are too heavy and
judging by the way Zod has her hands
down let's just assume they're around 20
pounds each so it's pretty heavy but
either way that's enough rambling we can
look at these chains as more of a weapon
than something that's holding us down if
you really think about it there's
nothing stopping us from whipping These
Chains onto Lord pyranten's head and
knocking him clean out not only that
there doesn't seem to be anyone wielding
a bow or some other kind of ranged
weapon which means we do have an
advantage of being able to keep our
distance while knocking these fools out
and using the chains that bind us if
we're quick and Savvy we could aim for
the mongrel here which will give us some
time to take out the other guard sitting
by the entrance for such a proud City
they don't seem to have much in the way
of protection especially being at the
Lord's Throne Room must be due to budget
cuts or something we could also knock
over this pit of fire right next to us
this would cause the carpet to ignite
and create another distraction that will
help us once we've escaped the building
and also there is still a pretty sizable
Village full of Warriors outside that
might want to chop us down so maybe we
should avoid that but we do need
something to help our escape a mission
after leaving there's no way we'll be
able to run away without anyone spawning
us and as you can see from our lack of
clothes we stick out like a sore thumb
so the first opportunity I'm going to
get is I'm going to take off my witchy
headdress and put on the clothes of the
locals that way I will stand out less
while it's true the cards are really
stacked against us there is a tiny
chance that we could make it out of here
live the mongrel here stops him before
the torture session begins letting him
know that Zod is capable of putting on a
majestic show they saw it all before the
mongrel gave the go-ahead to kill all of
her people she was able to fill the sky
with some blue flames the color of the
bonfire also changed blue hearing this
Lord Zod gives her a chance to show off
her moves in exchange for no torture
carefully Zod crawls over to this fire
pit and changes the flame from red to
blue chanting a mysterious phrase which
causes images to appear inside Lord
pyranton like a dummy dumdum leans in
closer and asks her what do the words
mean but that was his biggest mistake
Zod throws the Flames onto his face and
the [__] reacts by swinging his ax at
her wounding her but galsaur jumps over
on top of her and begs him to stop
stating that she's protected by the high
order of Asher under the scholars of
Pantheon ashburton he warns him that
their crops will dry up and food will
disappear leaving the village in ruin
hearing this the mongrel orders them to
be locked up while still clearly not
caring that his boss Lord pirantine here
is having his face still being burned to
a crispy crisp that night pyranton's men
attend to his burnt head as he demands
to be given more wine but his cup is
empty sucks to be him and he accuses the
mongrel of knowing that she was going to
do something meanwhile gal sewer here
wins is in pain from a deep wound on a
soldier remembering that golfer was kind
of nice to her she walks over takes a
flower petal off of her flower jacket
fixing the man up instantly and she lies
back down he says that pirantine will
kill them and why doesn't she show any
urgency in trying to escape this place
with her life pissing him off she asks
galsour who he is before he joined Asher
and was told that he was a nobody before
becoming a scholar Zod tells him to
think about what he truly wants before
they die and he drops to the ground
losing all hope waking up with a start
they see Lord's pyrantic clanging his
sword on the cell bars and the Man shows
off his newly mutilated face he curses
Zod for burning his face and in return
he burned her swamp and he tells her to
go take a look enjoy the view of the
destruction of her home and she looks
outside to see her home destroyed Zod
breaks down in tears and the scholar
questions whether she can do more with
her magical flowers insisting that she
uses it to free them convinced that's
when the witch stands up rips off a
chunk of flowers and blows up a magical
flame Zod breaks out of her chains
blowing up the stone wall and rushes
outside however she finds out that far
too late to save her swamp as she gets a
better look of the fire she realizes how
badly the destruction really is Galls
were demands that she joins him at the
pantheon but zot can't believe what has
happened that's when they spot Lord
pyranton heading towards them on
Horseback golsor drops to the ground it
grabs a very long stick Zodi uses her
powers to incinerate the Lord's horse
and he flies off of it begging the girl
not to harm him she walks over to Lord
pyranton and uses her powers to have his
body slowly sinked into the mud killing
him suddenly golsor walks over stabs Zod
in the stomach and rips her flower top
off he walks over to the Lord's
assistant kills him takes his horse and
rides off that's mean rude golsora sort
of looked like a nice guy but I guess
that's what you get for living in a
world where you really can't trust
anybody Zod here really let her guard
down I mean I know her home was just
destroyed but really you kind of need to
keep your wits about you even though
somehow she has come back to life which
isn't too bad she just doomed the world
to centuries of Torment under this
tyrannical scholar from a simple mistake
from simply not paying attention and
letting herself get stabbed and falling
into this mud pit and dying she doomed
the world to centuries of pain because
truly even Lord pyranton would have done
better with our magical trinket because
at least he was honest about being what
he was a bad guy golsor wasn't even
honest about it which makes it worse now
there's been a few telltale signs about
this man being evil that we should have
known all along now while it seems like
he did try to save us against pyranton
you have to think about it why would
someone who doesn't know us at all jump
over top of us lie about who we really
are just to save us out of the kindness
of their heart unfortunately there's far
too few of people like that in the world
which means he really wants us for
something which means that all of it was
just an act if she hadn't turned off her
I cannot trust anybody switch she
probably would have been able to avoid
getting stabbed by galsur and another
thing for a scholar this guy seemed
awfully self-centered about leaving the
prison cell shouldn't have been more at
peace with himself and more Zen if he
was a man of knowledge a man of Faith
while he is just a normal man prone to
his emotions usually those with such a
strong devout faith in their beliefs
shouldn't be too scared of death after
all he's probably going to go to a
better place than this apocal hellhole
this guy was hiding his true intentions
all along and now finally to my main
point why didn't she blow up the cell
door before her swamp was burnt to a
crisp it took a freaking suggestion from
our good uh friend golsor to even
attempt using the bloom to allow us to
escape if her powers are truly this
strong then she should have been able to
use it even zod's entire tribe was
brutally murdered but I guess somehow it
doesn't work against normal humans even
though she was able to blow up a
freaking wall made of stone but who am I
I'm just an anime guy I'm not a swamp
witch who had a lifetime of using magic
voodoo Powers ugh so annoyed if there's
one last suggestion that I could have
made for old Zod here if the bloom is
such a sought after price and can give
you powers of unimaginable magnitude
what's the stomper from throwing out a
few flowers into those flames and
attempt to put out the crazy Wildfire
which have just killed her entire swamp
it would have been worth a try she has a
crap ton of flowers on her shoulders but
if it doesn't work at least she tried
finishing up her explanation of what
happened the guardian can't believe his
eyes and he asks her how she's standing
here before him and he takes off his to
reveal an old grisly man who has
definitely been guarding this place for
a hell of a long time Zod confirms that
she's Alive by placing her hand on his
cheek and says can't you feel the warmth
and she sits down the guardian asks
himself if he's selfishly keeping the
bloom hidden away from mankind if it was
a good idea she asks if she can continue
on her story and he says yes and she
tells him that after many years have
passed the one small village has now
become a gigantic City seeing the
priorities of the scholars the people
become livid and they make a Ruckus
while this card full of books is being
wheeled inside of the city walls that's
when the people snap and one of the
protesters is viciously killed Faye here
is pushed away insisting that her fellow
Scholars go ahead and protect the books
man that's some commitment for books I'm
sure the local librarian loved her when
she was a little kid anyways she walks
off to a secluded location and takes a
breather from all the craziness and then
she hears an old man begging for food
Faye mentions that she's been here a
long time and asks why the people of
Ashraf begun to use violence she doesn't
even recognize this city and it isn't
any longer the peaceful Paradise she
once new he explains that the city has
come under a dark time with the death of
their long reigning King who left no
Sons The King ran away into the
mountains and never came back leaving
the city with no food and no leadership
she hands him some cash and repeats her
question about the violence and he
reveals that these Scholars aren't as
nice as they used to be they discovered
a life-changing Secret inside of their
Tower and won't share it with the people
Faye suggests that it might be too
insane of a power might be too insane of
a knowledge for the normal folk to
comprehend but the old man refuses to
believe her and begins chanting the word
doom and doom and doom and doom and doom
all over again it's kind of spooky
inside the tower his counselors informed
the grand Inquisitor that there aren't
enough soldiers to protect the library
and assure him that something bad will
happen he insists that everything will
be fine calling the pantheon an immortal
being that can't be harmed telling them
that the protesters will disperse after
enough time one of the counselors
suggests that they teach the normal folk
their ways but The Inquisitor recites
their sacred book reminding them that
they have no obligation to help those
peasants outside and that's when he
spots arriving and becomes super excited
and welcomes the girl expecting the girl
to have brought back a large index of
books he excuses everyone and tells them
to get out of the room and complains to
Faye about his counselor's lack of
knowledge asking to hear about the
pantheon Faye informs him that from the
instructions that he gave her she
reached a set of tunnels under the kamul
region where many of the vaults were
flooded and found sacred texts hidden
within this strange looking statue she
thought there might have been booby
traps but there was none only a pile
full of knowledge a treasure Trove that
she found and The Inquisitor asks her
surely you didn't leave the best books
behind in the wagon and Faye pulls out a
number of books that she found and The
Inquisitor opens one up and is unable to
read the text and then he has an idea
that night the hunched over man walks
through the building's hallways and
opens up a secret door and heads
underground he enters this forbidden
room where cut open naked bodies lie
strewn around and find an older golf
sword playing Picasso with his victim's
Blood The Inquisitor asks information
from golsor but he complains about being
imprisoned saying he's their oldest and
wisest scholar in demands to be set free
The Inquisitor denies him his freedom
but he gives the book to Gulf sewer and
tells him that it's like nothing he's
ever seen before and it may be able to
activate the Bloom's power gaulasaur
recognizes the text and complains again
about being locked up in prison for such
a long time yeah we know get over it The
Inquisitor refuses to let him out
knowing that his impulses will take over
he asks gulsor what would he need to
unleash the power from the bloom and
golsor tells him that he could have
anything he ever dreamed of hearing this
like a fool The Inquisitor offers to
bring the tools needed for his ritual in
exchange for sharing the power hold the
phone did he just do that did he just
give the keys to the kingdom to golsor
yes he did let's see how it plays out
golf sword then stuffs a flower into his
mouth and chews on it a little bit and
spits it out and gives it to the Man
psychotically requesting that he needs
more blood a lot more blood Outside The
Inquisitor walks past Faye having a
conversation with her friend and she's
worried about the protester starving
which may be the very thing that finally
causes the city to crumble he decides to
go go up to the upper walls and take a
quick look and sends Gull Source chewed
up flower out onto the entire city
meanwhile the locked up scholar recites
a set of old and ancient phrases and
begins taking control of everyone
outside who begins to repeat his words
turning them into mindless followers
they just massively screwed up big time
by giving that book to this crooked
Inquisitor she just gave him access to
almost unlimited power okay here's
another case example of someone who
might have looked righteous at first and
holy but now they're secretly plotting
to take over the entire world Chase
these heroin chicks can't just get a
break but again it was even more obvious
this time that we were dealing with an
evil dictator I mean just look at the
way this guy looks from being a
religious Inquisitor He's Surely doing
something that no other truly righteous
person would ever do a whole Army of
starving villagers are perched outside
of his door day in and day out and he
does nothing to help them this is a
cowardly and definitely not a way a
leader should be acting kind of deal
it's also really stupid of him because
like I said earlier did this guy just
give the person he's tormented forever a
position of power no why would you do
that there's no way things are going to
end up hunky-dory here's some of the
signs that Faye should have looked out
for the first thing that she should have
done was to question the old man more
about what happened to the city while he
might seem a little out there he looks
to be homeless and would have a much
more keen idea about what's going on in
the streets and this would have drove
home how seriously messed up her home
has gotten over this long unspecified
amount of time she's been gone for one
of the telltale signs is that Asher has
been using violent weapons against those
protesting for food it's obvious that
this leader is seriously mismanaging his
City to the point that he doesn't even
care about it not only that we've just
heard that their Old King has died and
is told that he's been rumored to have
actually ran off to the Mountainside why
would he do this it was probably driven
away or it's possible that he saw what
this place was turning into and got the
hell out of Dodge that being said how
the hell has The Inquisitor never been
caught transporting dead bodies into
galsource prison Gaul sewer seems like
he's been kept here a long time meaning
that they constantly would be bringing
in dead bodies for the scholar to feed
off of or experiment or in his words
research it's just surprising that no
one working for The Inquisitor ever let
it slip and that this cycle is likely
hiring a group of people to farm dead
bodies but I guess it doesn't matter now
that's when he stops the procession and
they realize that they've reached the
pantheon and they're ready to kill for
food Faye and her friend noticed the
Ruckus and walk out to confront them
insisting that their food reserves
aren't enough for everyone however they
don't care the protesters push forward
as they're brutally chopped down
reluctant Fey here joins in on the
action with dozens of city Folk being
killed golsor uses the ancient text to
turn the blood of the people into a
floating orb which travels all the way
into his prison cell covering him in a
ball of red flowers suddenly he walks
over to The Inquisitor and drains the
life from his eyes transferring
galsour's body into the old man outside
Faye demands that they stop the violence
and she insists they'll be taught how to
survive they can teach them the kind of
foods to eat what's poisonous what's not
but girls who appears from the holy
Tower and rejects her statement but she
doesn't realize that it's called sewer
she thinks it's the old Inquisitor and
the possess Inquisitor tells them that
only great minds can comprehend the
knowledge inside ordering these peasants
to leave or be killed hearing this they
press forward to The Inquisitor who
slices them all up in one Fell Swoop
using some really long spooky looking
fingernail things FaZe friend recognizes
that he's been possessed Furious he
rushes towards golf tour but that was
his biggest mistake he gets cut up to
bits right in front of Faye and is told
that they were being traitors to the
Usher gaulser announces that he'll be an
oracle to the world and raises fate into
the air they end up on the Pantheon's
roof where he proclaims world domination
he will be the knowledge to all Faye
reminds the possessed man that their
oath is to protect their sacred books
but he doesn't care and throws her into
this Bell Faye stands back up with his
sword drawn however she's far too weak
to do anything meanwhile golf tour's
original body wakes back up and opens up
a fissure of light in the sky burning
the inquisitor's body and sending him
spiraling down from the top of the
pantheon damn
this is more than just from zero to 100
this went from 100 to 502 seconds Faye
just got herself seriously screwed over
and even if she manages to fight off
whatever is going to attack how the hell
is she going to get down from this
building there doesn't seem to be any
ladders laying around and we're perched
up on the highest point for thousands of
miles that is terrifying now while Faye
here was watching the evil man transform
she had a pretty clear window to realize
this holy man that she once knew has now
begun killing his own this guy is an
absolute Menace and he's been holding on
to an almost Supernatural amount of
power and apparently has no limit to
what it can do that being said if Faye
had made an attempt to attack him during
any of the fighting we've might have
been able to call it a day much earlier
the other soldiers could have tried to
replan their attacks from when they
witnessed this entire group of
protesters get slaughtered instantly
they would have quickly realized that
there's no way they could have beaten
him through conventional means it'd only
get all of the soldiers killed if it
were me I would have uh said hey bros
maybe we need to think about this we
need to use the element of surprise if
we get too close we're dead and it looks
like he can can launch his attacks to
far distances as well by banding
everyone together our group could have
attempted to throw their weapons at The
Inquisitor from the short time we've
seen him we've only seen him use his
Newfound powers for offensive purposes
and most people would also probably
assume that he also has some sort of
magical armor as well and you're
probably right but we gotta try
something Zod explains that Gauls were
awakened and destroyed the pantheon and
gathered an army of disciples with his
Newfound Powers the guardian then
announces Doom and Gloom knowing that
the bloom is a powerful weapon that is
never meant to be abused he demands that
he stop her sad story but Zod insists
that he has the secret to the Stars
whatever that means the guardian refuses
to listen but she continues on anyways
explaining the golf swords Army crossed
the lands with a nudist Army carrying
him from outside of the city and ended
up in this peaceful village where they
spot thousands of soldiers coming their
way the women close up their doors while
the men raided their weapons hiding away
as their enemies approached but there's
too many they're cornered and
slaughtered one by one with gals who are
announcing Victory however he informs
his troops that he has another surprise
up his sleeve for tonight this old man
watches in shock as golf store orders
his soldiers to continue occupying the
lands being shot at by him that's when
the old man is instantly killed and his
quest for Domination resumes this young
couple walks out of hiding to see their
entire Village destroyed This Ginger
girl day realizes that everyone they
know and loved is now gone that night
they walk through the wreckage of their
old town and the young boy goal finds a
piece of the blue he huddles around a
campfire while informing his girlfriend
that while he hasn't found any food he's
found a flower so she grabs the flower
and throws it into the fire turning blue
later they stare into the stars as it
morphs while romantically caressing each
other oh so sweet but suddenly a group
of soldiers approached them day suggests
that they run but her boyfriend insists
that there's nowhere to go gold thanks
his girlfriend for the time they share
together before they're brutally killed
golsor's Army has just taken another set
of innocent lives with no stopping in
sight okay now these two lovebirds just
completely gave up and accepted death
don't do that at least try something but
honestly there was not much that they
could have done to avoid being
slaughtered but either way this is how
to beat anime and I gotta figure out a
way for our young couple to get the hell
out of this so here we go now the first
mistake they made was hiding clearly out
in the open and just lying around
without any protection they don't have
any weapons on them and it's not a
stretch to think that the soldiers would
be roaming the city that they've just
captured in fact this would be more than
just a common sense assumption they
should not have decided to stick around
and chill I can't imagine what were they
thinking to do that it makes no sense I
mean I get it I love a good night sky as
much as the next bro and it's beautiful
I mean look at the stars they're
gorgeous but it would have been a lot
safer to stay inside one of the many
abandoned houses in the recently
deserted village or even stay in the
freaking woods and don't light a fire
but if they're inside the deserted
village yes there's a chance of still
being caught but if they were quiet and
kept their mouth shut and hid in the
dark they may have had a slim chance of
surviving now another option would have
been to hide somewhere outside of the
village the woods like I said this may
seem like the simplest way of avoiding
capture but we have to remember that
this is way back in the day and there
could have been any number of dangerous
animals or plants or things that they
don't know to avoid which could have
been the reason why they decided to stay
where they did but even after messing
all that up and making the mistake to
stick around Gull was clearly lying to
his girlfriend when telling her there
was nowhere to run because uh the wall
behind them is completely destroyed and
they could have easily jumped over
either side these soldiers are out to
kill them and aren't exactly fast moving
they even decided to slowly raise their
blades into the air before landing a
killing blow I mean come on I tried to
soften it in the beginning but really
there was so many chances to make an
easy Escape but they decided not to take
it that's stupidville don't be stupid
sod requests a story from the guardian
wanting to know more about the bloom he
reveals that it was a mythical being
when he was younger explaining that the
gods fought without purpose this dead
God passed his dreams onto his sons
becoming mythical creatures that were
responsible for creating the world they
created themselves a new children which
weren't really properly taken care of
and they were forced to survive on their
own these Sons were responsible for
creating natural disaster type of events
which slowly caused Humanity to grow
angry with them They begged for mercy
from their gods but they were rejected
and that's when a single man gathered a
group of followers showing them the way
to kill the God's children and this man
became a king and he hunted down each
God finally killing his own Creator and
after this King's death he left a
lineage of Mighty Warriors that
constantly kept changing the guardian
mentions one man who stood up upon a
hill and found a bed of flowers inside
of this strange skull formation
breathing it in he falls down and
awakens a deep power this man saw some
really trippy stuff driving him crazy
enough to foresee a world made only of
dust he uses his intuition to save them
and keep everyone away from the bloom
gifting mankind the trait of ignorance
the man tried his best to fight off
everyone who came for his Secrets
eventually succumbing to a skilled
Archer this led to him acquiring the
role of Guardian which created a cycle
of those who protected the bloom for
centuries speaking with Zod he says the
two kings have been at War since he was
born causing them to wreak havoc on his
Fields losing crops and resources and
Furious he decided to take matter into
his own hands killing another man to
find the same skull formation lying in
snow he recalls taking a breath of the
flowers and hallucinates something
extraordinary something along the lines
of the meaning of life and all that jazz
and from his trippy experience he
believes that everything is meaningless
and so he takes on the role of a
guardian to make sure that this dark
secret is kept from Humanity forever Zod
asks him why he didn't destroy the bloom
after realizing its power and he tells
her that him personally removing a
mystery of the night was against his
power and he couldn't do it he only was
able to become a gatekeeper hiding the
connection between man and God and
that's when he complains about being
tired and old and insists that she gets
rid of the bloom and leave and tells her
to let him die with no hope of survival
but Zod refuses to give up and raises
her flowers into the air creating a
glimmer of blue light and uh if none of
this is making sense to you don't feel
bad I'm not following along all that
great either but back to the story she
details how these three assassins were
observing galsour's Army and watched
them go about their day and they
question why anyone would fight for him
the this bald man's Sparrow Crow
mentions that their king golf sword
promised his followers eternal life in
exchange for complete Devotion to his
cause attracting the weak-hearted his
partner Falcon Crow sensing a theme Here
falconrow confidently suggests that they
each fight to survive while these people
fight to escape death Sparrow Crow
scolds her for cursing them as War wages
on between these two armies causing
violent deaths on both sides this
Soldier shoots his Arrow up into an
incoming Airship as the bird group blows
fire over the soldiers being shocked at
the destruction around them inside of
the city informants warned their leaders
of this incoming threat with only two
days until arrival and yet again another
nudist inspired person this Mohawk lady
kesselran questions why King uxan hasn't
protected this place insisting that they
do something to help Falcon Crow informs
her that nothing will save them with
galsura being an immortal being but
Mohawk lady is certain that they can
simply fly over and kill him so they
give it a shot they know that his
Fortress is beyond the Great Swamp and
is protected by large iron walls Mohawk
reminds him golf stores airships go in
and out of the city giving them a chance
to board one of them and ride it on over
to his home base and they set the date
for their big mission to start tomorrow
and they have no idea that this is going
to be a big big mistake okay from the
last few stories that we've just heard I
definitely advised attacking golf swore
ahead on I know these guys don't have
any smartphones or Google to allow them
to know that this guy is a really damn
Evil deadly scholar but they do have the
ability to fly and see what kind of
Destruction has occurred at the hands of
galsour if I was them I'd question their
thought process a little bit that three
barely armed people could manage to
bring down a whole nation of evildoers
and a freaking demigod as their leader
bird group should have taken their
wingsuits and flew the hell out of Dodge
because there's absolutely zero chance
of this pilling well but I guess they're
ready to die for their cause so there's
no telling them otherwise but just take
a look at these three they barely got
any armor on and barely anything on at
all and if someone were to fire an arrow
or freaking rock at them through their
Wing suits they would go crashing right
into the ground all the cards are act
against them and so I'd suggest to them
if they would listen to go fly away to a
better land that doesn't have any evil
ruler is definitely a better option
watching as the Airship flies from above
they wait until the opposing Army flies
over their catapults sprinting off the
rooftop and using their wingsuits to
remove themselves the crew makes it
safely on top getting ready for payback
later they look down at the pure death
and destruction questioning why these
innocent lands have been ruined that's
when Sparrow Crow spots the black
Pantheon who their Master told them to
look out for looking even worse and more
evil than they could have ever imagined
inside these disciples approach golf
tour informing him of their return from
the uxan front he asks to know if
they're safe to relocate beyond the
mountains golf sword gestures towards
them and causes a blinding light to emit
from the tower understanding what this
means he gets up and announces that the
rebirthing process would now begin they
take these corpses and lay them onto an
altar and the dead bodies are brutally
mutilated draining all of the blood from
the recently murdered victims geez this
guy sure loves his blood and is willing
to do whatever it takes to get more of
it getting ready for their final mission
Falcon Hawk here insists that they need
to head in now any longer and the ship
will land leaving them no space to fly
over the Iron Wall wishing them luck and
hoping they'll meet again soon someday
by not being too optimistic about it
Sparrow crow flies off as the other two
infiltrate the Airship flying into this
cockpit and calmly taking out the pilot
Falcon Hawk informs his teammate that
he's going to take out the others as she
Pilots their ship sneaking through the
hallway he finds a group of workers and
calmly walks over alerting them to his
presence they rush over towards him but
the man is too damn quick taking out all
three until this big guy arrives to
fight suddenly kesselran is taken down
by the pilot who turns out to be not
dead strangling her and causing the ship
to tilt she manages to maneuver the ship
downwards giving her enough space to
kick the man off and sends him flying
off to his death sparrowhawk's spear is
broken by the big man here while Sparrow
Crow fights with an enemy soldier who
cuts her down Falcon Hawk manages to get
his enemy to the ground but a pool of
lava flows over and burns the both of
them alive well that sucks bummer seeing
this Castle Wren flies out of the danger
and is pushed straight into Gaul sewer's
Lair oh no and he manages to stop the
ship using his Bloom Powers as kesselran
crashes down struggling to keep this
massive aircraft from destroying his
home kesselran wakes up confused and
spots their target their arch nemesis
standing right in front of her she
Sprints towards him and slices his back
open before falling into this pool of
blood wow this is an absolute train
wreck this could not have gone any worse
two out of the three people dressed like
birds have just been killed and cows
around here is the only one left now she
could have easily just got knocked out
from the blast and is in a very bad
position concerning that we just
absolutely pretty much destroyed
golsora's house he's not going to be a
happy camper about the redecoration I'm
sure probably isn't going to hire us
again to do this job anytime soon
luckily for us it seems like we've
actually managed to distract the map by
leaving this Airship and allowing it to
Tumble right down to his front door
because now he's way too focused on
keeping it from crashing into him to
even realize that we've fallen inside
this does make you ask the question
though how strong is the bloom really
we've never seen it used for many
purposes and there's an argument to be
made that it gets weaker over time but
as of now keeping a probably over a 5
000 pound ship from crashing and killing
golf so it must mean that it's pretty
dang strong now kesaron may have just
been submerged into a pool of blood it's
definitely not getting out of this
situation without getting some kind of
blood disease there's not much he could
have done with golf sword even in his
weakened State she just isn't strong
enough to take him on just like all the
others but however if Kessler knew how
powerful the bloom was she could have
tried to take it off of him because
there's no way that this magical trinket
doesn't come with the ability to
regenerate any of his lost limbs because
I'm sure it does which means he's
probably impossible to kill so really
the only shot that she had to take him
out would have been to try to take off
the bloom and chop off his head and hope
for the best and run away but she didn't
do that so I guess kesaran here messed
up big time and is probably going to die
golsor notices the girl and lifts her up
into the air breaking each and every
single bone in her body and she cry
questions if God suffered as galsour's
Lair blows up leaving the bloom to
travel Downstream away from the pantheon
the bloom emerges out of the water and
reanimates itself into Zod who wow so
that's how she gets back into the story
I told you this is a weird one she
finally awakens again and takes back
what's hers meanwhile gals Surya wakes
up in a now destroyed version of his
home and spots a blue light shining from
this mountain now Zod has finally
completed her story up until the current
day she mentions that the bloom never
forgets who has stared into the darkness
explaining that she found the guardian
in this exact same way he responds by
saying that the bloom has allowed him to
see things unimaginable to the human eye
wondering why the knowledge has come at
such a deadly cost Zod insists that he
can rest and assures him that she'll fix
the mistakes made to leave Mankind in
peace once again but that's when the
guardian warns her that someone is
approaching before taking his final
breath Zod thanks him for his service
giving the man his last bit of womanly
affection before he passes away and now
the story has come full circle she
finally reunites with her arch nemesis
golf Sur who remembers exactly who she
is he never bothers to remember anyone
else even after being alive for
centuries golf Seward tells her that
she's going to be killed for her Bloom
just as she was killed hundreds of years
ago Zod announces that these are the
last few flowers that the world will
ever see but golf tour doesn't care he
wants to keep the bloom for himself it's
like every bit of it dry she warns him
not to use it any longer and he orders
the girl to be killed she shot down by
golf swords lackeys and he walks over
cursing her to death and so Zod lets out
one final chant consuming the men in a
blue light using the last of her powers
to reanimate a group of skeletal
Warriors which come out of their graves
and kill golsor's men he tries to fight
them off but his powers are now far too
weak the evil man is restrained by zod's
Lackey and he gets split into two and
she gets up walks over oh by the way
he's still not dead so she walks over
and grabs his heart and rips it out
ordering him to look at the stars before
crushing the organ and an explosion hits
the surrounding area sending Zod off
into space and flowers drop back to
Earth and now the world is finally safe
from this crazy dollar and that's the
end of the story see I told you it's a
weird one thanks for listening